Speaker 1: , David.
Do you believe that people whose hobby is
politics actually get anything done politically?
This is a I want to be careful in how I talk
about this, because if I were to say people
who just follow politics as a as a hobby and
a source of entertainment don't get a damn
thing done, I think it would potentially be
disaffecting to many people.
My view is that and we've done interviews
on this before and it's an important question.
We've talked about it with Rachel bytecode
here and with other people.
Political hobbyists don't get much done themselves.
If they only remain political hobbyists.
However, they may, number one, by sharing
information on social media, get other people
to go beyond being merely political hobbyists
and being actual political activists who get
things done.
But for many people, being a political hobbyist
is the entry path into being more of an activist,
someone who actually calls elected officials,
organizes, does voter registration, volunteers
for candidates, et cetera, et cetera, et cetera.
So if the question it's the devil is in how
you ask through the devil's in the details
of the question, do people who never go beyond
merely following politics like entertainment,
help to achieve change?
Very, very little, hopefully they at least
vote not all political hobbyists even vote,
but to the extent that they do, voting is
important.
If the question is, can being a political
hobbyist lead to being someone that actually
does achieve change by becoming an organizer
or someone who volunteers for campaigns or
whatever else?
The answer is absolutely yes.
And I know tons of people and many are in
our audience who started just by watching
shows, shows like this and other shows and
voted, but then eventually really became engaged.
And I can think of people in lots of different
parts of the country where that's the case.
So what is important is not to dismiss those
who are interested in politics and follow
it as a hobby, as people who can never get
anything done.
It's a matter of encouraging them to get more
involved.
And there are so many ways that that can be
done, either running for something at the
local level, volunteering for a local, state
or national election and doing phone banking
and text banking and all these different things.
People who one other thing right now, the
candidate that raises more money in a race
is more likely to win.
It's not 100 percent.
It's not correlated at one.
But there's a correlation between raising
more money and being able to and ultimately
winning.
If you become a political hobbyist and you
donate money, you are also involved in a way
that materially affects outcomes.
I wish that it wasn't the case that our political
system depended on money in that way.
It's a disgusting, corrosive system that must
be changed.
But if you're not only a political hobbyist,
but someone who donates to candidates that
you believe in, you are also having an impact.
And we know that.
And there's a reason that raising money is
so important and such an important factor
in signaling who might actually win an election.
So let's embrace the political hobbyists to
do more rather than writing them off as people
who make no difference.
And the truth is, most people in my audience
are political hobbyists.
Some percentage of them are more than that.
And hopefully we can encourage that number
to grow even further.
Let me know your thoughts.
We also have a great bonus show for you today.
The bonus show is only exclusively for our
website members and Patreon donors you can
sign up at join Pakman Dotcom.
You can sign up at Patreon dot com The David
Pakman Show.
Either way, you'll get instant access to the
bonus show.
Why not do it before April is gone?
You have just hours to go.
I'll see you then.